Narrator:
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
GET YOUR ABS WHILE EATING
PROTEIN PANCAKES.
OH-HO.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
OOH, I LIKE THAT.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I HAPPEN TO LIKE
THIS IDEA.
I DON'T HAVE ONE OF THESE
IN MY PORTFOLIO.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I WILL NOT TAKE LESS THAN 10%.
IT'S JUST NOT WORTH IT.
DAMN.
KEVIN MADE YOU AN AWFUL OFFER.
I'LL MAKE YOU A BETTER OFFER.
Narrator: THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
IT SELLS FOR $42.95.
$42 FOR PANCAKES?!
THAT'S CRAZY.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?!
THIS IS WHY I NEED YOU.
I HAVE A FULL-TIME JOB.
I CAN'T DO IT FOR YOU.
I'M GONNA DO SOMETHING I NEVER,
EVER THOUGHT I WOULD DO.
CLUTCH MY PEARLS.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
Narrator: FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A LOW-CALORIE VERSION
OF A FAVORITE BREAKFAST TREAT.
HI, SHARKS.
I AM ASHLEY DRUMMONDS.
AND I AM JOSH McCLELLAND,
AND WE ARE FROM TAMPA, FLORIDA.
OUR COMPANY IS ABS,
AND WE ARE SEEKING $120,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 40% OF OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, IT IS TIME TO
GET SERIOUS ABOUT YOUR
HEALTH AND FITNESS,
AND WE ALL KNOW
THE FIRST STEP IS EATING RIGHT.
SO YOU CAN SAY GOODBYE
TO SUGAR, FLAVOR, FAT,
AND HAPPINESS, OF COURSE.
INSTEAD, THOUGH,
YOU CAN WHIP UP A PILE
OF NICE, BLAND VEGETABLES,
TWO CRISP PIECES OF CARDBOARD,
AND THEN TOP IT ALL OFF WITH
A DELICIOUS PROTEIN SHAKE.
MMM!
CHALKY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
OR YOU CAN ACTUALLY EAT
WHAT YOU REALLY WANT FOR
BREAKFAST IN THE MORNING...
...ABS PROTEIN PANCAKES.
THAT'S RIGHT -- GET YOUR ABS
WHILE EATING PROTEIN PANCAKES.
OH-HO.
DON'T EVEN DO THAT TO US.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AH, NOTHING.
ONE SERVING --
THIS IS FOUR FLUFFY PANCAKES,
WHICH IS UNDER 250 CALORIES,
OVER 24 GRAMS OF PROTEIN, 100%
ALL-NATURAL AND GLUTEN-FREE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT ABS START
IN THE KITCHEN, NOT IN THE GYM,
AND NOW
YOU CAN ENJOY PANCAKES
AS PART OF A HEALTHY
NUTRITION PROGRAM.
SO, SHARKS, WHO'S READY
TO HELP US GIVE AMERICA BACK
ONE OF THEIR FAVORITE
BREAKFAST FOODS?
Both:
ABS-OLUTELY GUILT-FREE.
WHO'S HUNGRY?
YOU GUYS WANT
TO TRY SOME PANCAKES?
WE ALL ARE.
WE'RE ALWAYS HUNGRY.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT VANILLA CAKE BATTER.
THESE ONES?
YOU HAVE CHOCOLATE CHIP,
DAYMOND.
AND YOU'RE WELCOME TO
GRAB THE BAG AND LOOK AT
THE MACROS, AS WELL.
I KNOW I'M THE CHOCOLATE ONE,
RIGHT?
WHAT ARE THE SAUCES,
ASHLEY?
Drummonds: SO, ONE OF THEM IS AN
ALL-NATURAL SUGAR-FREE SYRUP...
THANK YOU.
...AND THE OTHER ONE IS
AN ALL-NATURAL ALMOND BUTTER,
WHICH IS A HEALTHY ALTERNATIVE
TO TOP THE PANCAKES WITH.
Cuban:
IT'S ACTUALLY NOT BAD.
I MEAN, WHEN YOU FIRST TASTE IT,
IT TASTES LIKE ANGEL FOOD CAKE.
IS MINE GLUTEN-FREE, TOO?
YES.
THEY'RE ALL GLUTEN-FREE.
ALL THREE.
Cuban: OH, WOW.
BECAUSE MOST GLUTEN-FREE
PRODUCTS TASTE LIKE CRAP.
EXACTLY. YEAH.
SO, LET'S SEE.
THEY HAVE AN AFTERTASTE.
A LITTLE BIT.
YEAH.
WHAT'S THAT AFTERTASTE?
A LITTLE BIT OF AFTERTASTE.
IT'S PROBABLY THE STEVIA.
PROBABLY THE STEVIA.
WE USE
A NATURAL SWEETENER
INSTEAD OF SPLENDA
OR ANY ARTIFICIAL SWEETENERS.
[ CLEARS THROAT ]
IT'S A LITTLE DRY, THOUGH.
WHY IS IT SO DRY?
IT'S JUST BECAUSE
IT'S A PROTEIN-POWDER BLEND
THAT WE'VE CREATED
THAT ALSO HAS A COCONUT FLOUR
TO KEEP IT GLUTEN-FREE,
INSTEAD OF USING, LIKE,
A WHOLE-WHEAT FLOUR.
O'Leary: WHY DO WE HAVE TO BE
GLUTEN-FREE?
THAT'S A SUBSEGMENT OF A LARGER
MARKET THAT, IF THIS --
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE.
IF IT TASTES GOOD,
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WELL, BUT I DON'T THINK --
RIGHT.
I THINK IT COULD TASTE BETTER
IF THERE WAS A GLUTEN VERSION
WITH MORE WHEAT IN IT.
WHICH WE'RE VERY MUCH, OP--
YOU KNOW, OPEN TO.
RIGHT.
NO, ACTUALLY, KEVIN,
YOU KNOW WHAT? THE MORE I EAT...
YOU GET USED TO IT?
...THE BETTER.
HOW MANY CALORIES?
THAT ONE RIGHT THERE
IS 250 WITH --
FOR ALL THREE?
YES.
ONE SERVING.
THAT IS ONE SERVING, YES.
I JUST WANT
TO ASK ONE QUESTION.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
THIS IDEA?
OKAY, WELL, ACTUALLY,
THE ABS IS AN ACRONYM.
IT STANDS FOR
"AUTHENTIC BEAUTY AND STRENGTH."
SO, WE BOTH WERE IN
THE FITNESS INDUSTRY,
DOING THE TYPICAL DIETS THAT
YOU HAVE TO DO FOR PHOTO SHOOTS.
AND, BEING A FEMALE, I REALLY
STRUGGLED WITH MY SELF-ESTEEM.
AND WHAT WERE YOU DOING
IN THE FITN-- YOU WERE MODELS,
OR YOU WERE NUTRITIONISTS,
TRAINERS, WHAT WAS YOUR --
WE WERE TRAINERS.
TRAINERS.
WE ALSO WERE DOING
JUST, LIKE, AMATEUR PHOTO SHOOTS
AND STUFF
TO BUILD OUR PORTFOLIO.
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD OF THESE,
AND WHAT YEAR DID YOU START?
IT HAS BEEN SELLING
FOR 11 MONTHS,
AND WE JUST WENT RIGHT OVER
$100,000 IN SALES.
AND THAT'S ALL --
THAT'S NOT BAD.
WOW.
YEAH.
McClelland:
1,600 UNITS SOLD TOTAL.
HOW DO -- HOW DO YOU SELL THEM?
1,600 UNITS? THANK YOU.
IT'S ALL DIRECTLY THROUGH
THE WEBSITE, FOR THE MOST PART.
DO YOU HAVE A LOT OF REPEAT
BUSINESS PROVING THAT PEOPLE
ARE WILLING TO EAT IT
A SECOND TIME?
YES.
I'M TELLING YOU GUYS,
THE LONGER I EAT IT,
YOU GET USED TO IT,
RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
IT'S ACTUALLY GOOD.
NO, NO, IT'S GOOD, MARK.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
WHAT ARE YOUR NUMBERS
LIKE? WHAT DOES IT COST
YOU TO MAKE A PACKAGE?
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
WHAT ARE THE MARGINS?
OKAY, SO, IT COSTS ANYWHERE
FROM $12 TO $14
DEPENDING ON THE FLAVOR
TO MAKE THE PACKAGE,
AND IT SELLS --
TO MAKE IT?
YES.
WOW.
CLUTCH MY PEARLS.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THAT'S CRAZY.
NOW, IS THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE MAKING IT IN YOUR HOME,
AND YOU'RE NOT USING --
HOW MUCH
ARE YOU SELLING IT FOR?
$42.95 RETAIL.
IT SELLS FOR $42.95 --
$42 FOR PANCAKES?!
[ ALL EXCLAIMING ]
WHOA!
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?!
STOP THE MADNESS!
COME ON!
THAT'S WHERE
HER SALES COME FROM.
SHE'S SOLD THREE!
$42 FOR PANCAKES?
Herjavec: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S CRAZY.
IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE THINKING
IN TERMS OF BISQUICK.
NO, I'M JUST THINKING.
RIGHT.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT OUR MARKET
IS A FITNESS MARKET
WHO SPENDS $40 TO $50
ON A POUND OF PROTEIN POWDER.
I CAN EAT THESE PANCAKES
OR BUY A CAR.
[ LAUGHS ]
THAT'S MY CHOICE.
Cuban: YEAH, BUT THAT'S NOT
REALLY THE QUESTION.
YOU WON'T HAVE ABS, THOUGH.
Greiner:
WHY DOES IT COST SO MUCH?
IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE HAVING TO
ORDER IN SUCH LOW QUANTITIES.
BECAUSE YOUR BASE
IN THIS WHOLE THING
IS A CUSTOM PROTEIN BLEND
THAT'S ALSO ALL-NATURAL.
IT'S NOT FLOURS.
SO, IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE
DOING THIS IN YOUR KITCHEN
AND YOU'RE ORDERING
LITTLE AMOUNTS.
WELL, WE DO HAVE
A CO-PACKER THAT DOES IT.
Y-YOU'RE NOT MAKING THIS
IN YOUR KITCHEN.
OH, YOU DO HAVE A CO-PACKER.
THIS IS THE COST
OF A CO-PACKER, YES.
IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE ORDERING --
EVERYTHING.
HOW LOW COULD YOU GET IT
IF YOU WERE SELLING MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH?
$7 TO $8 A PACKAGE.
SO, IT'S STILL
EXPENSIVE INGREDIENTS...
RIGHT.
...AND THAT'S
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
RIGHT.
BUT BODY BUILDERS
AND PEOPLE WHO COMPETE,
THEY'RE NOT --
THEY'RE NOT PRICE CONSCIOUS,
IS BASICALLY
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
CORRECT.
LOOK, GUYS, WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS AMAZING SO FAR.
YOU DESERVE A LOT OF CREDIT,
AND YOU'RE MAKING MONEY.
THE PROBLEM IS,
YOU'RE NOT A COMPANY YET.
YOU'RE A PRODUCT
THAT YOU HUSTLE.
FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
AH.
YOU KNOW, BIG CHALLENGE --
HOW DO YOU VALUE
THIS COMPANY?
YEAH,
BIG CHALLENGE WOULD BE --
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T
THINK YOU CAME IN HERE RE--
NECESSARILY ASKING
FOR AN UNREASONABLE VALUATION.
WHERE YOU'RE AT RIGHT NOW,
I CAN SEE IT.
I JUST GOT SHOCKED
WHEN I HEARD $42.
MM-HMM.
I JUST FIND IT CHALLENGING
TO -- TO GO TO --
AT $42 FOR THE PANCAKES,
IT'S PRETTY EXPENSIVE.
UH, AND I JUST DON'T KNOW
IF YOU CAN LAST AT THAT LEVEL,
SO, UH, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW,
YOU GUYS LOOK GREAT.
THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY DOES CARE ABOUT
BEING HEALTHY AND LOOKING BETTER
AND ALL OF THAT,
BUT I PERSONALLY DIDN'T LIKE
THE FLAVOR OF IT.
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE TO REALLY
LOVE WHAT I GET BEHIND,
SO I'M OUT.
ROBERT?
UM...
I THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW,
MARK AND I DID NUTS 'N MORE,
AND WE'VE DONE VERY WELL
WITH THAT.
AND SINCE THEN, I'VE DONE
A BUNCH OF OTHER THINGS
IN THE FITNESS CATEGORY,
SO WE'VE NAVIGATED
OUR WAY THROUGH THAT.
UM...I THINK
YOUR PRICE IS TOO HIGH.
BUT I LOVE
THE PACKAGING, ESPECIALLY.
I MEAN, IT'S GREAT.
AND I COULD SEE
A PRODUCT EXTENSION...
Drummonds: THANK YOU.
...CUPCAKE MIX
AND OTHER THINGS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY,
MAYBE IT'S THE PACKAGE,
BUT I'M IN A REALLY
SHARKY MOOD TODAY.
I'LL DO $120,000 FOR 50%.
Cuban: OHH.
YOU OFFERED 40%,
I WENT UP TO 50%.
WHY, ROBERT?
IT'S HIS MONEY.
HE CAN DO -- DO WHAT HE WANTS.
HARDWORKING GIRL.
WHY WOULD YOU GO TO 50%?
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
ASHLEY AND JOSH ARE SEEKING
$120,000 FOR 40% EQUITY
IN THEIR BUSINESS,
ABS PROTEIN PANCAKES.
I'LL DO $120,000 FOR 50%.
Cuban: OHH.
YOU OFFERED 40%,
I WENT UP TO 50%.
WHY, ROBERT?
IT'S HIS MONEY.
HE CAN DO -- DO WHAT HE WANTS.
HARDWORKING GIRL.
WHY WOULD YOU GO TO 50%?
O'Leary: WELL, LET -- LET ME --
LET ME MAKE IT EASIER FOR YOU
TO MAKE A DECISION.
I'M OUT.
I DON'T GET THIS.
THIS STUFF TASTES LIKE CRAP.
I DON'T GET IT.
NOTHING AGAINST YOU, BUT...
YUCK.
IT'S LIKE EATING CARDBOARD.
I FINISHED MINE, SO --
BY THE WAY, I LIKED THEM.
I LIKED THEM.
YOU EITHER UNDERSTAND
THE FITNESS BENEFITS
OR YOU DON'T.
I LOOK AT
THE INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITY
AS A DISCIPLINED
FINANCIAL INVESTOR, ROBERT...
WELL...
...AND SAY THAT THIS IS
A VERY SMALL, VERTICAL MARKET.
KEVIN, YOU HAVE TO -- YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND THE INDUSTRY.
YOU ARE DEFINITELY
THE "BEFORE"...
[ LAUGHS ]
...AND I'M DEFINITELY
THE "AFTER."
YOU MAY SAY THAT,
BUT I'M TRYING TO MAKE MONEY.
ME TOO.
AND I THINK THIS IS
A TINY LITTLE VERTICAL OF PEOPLE
THAT LIKE TO EAT CRAPPY STUFF.
YOU GUYS ARE EARLY.
AT LEAST TASTE-WISE.
YOU'RE EARLY.
YOU'VE DONE GREAT
YOUR FIRST YEAR.
IT'S A LONG-TERM PLAY.
$120,000, 50%.
SO --
I BELIEVE
I'M THE ONLY OFFER.
ROBERT, ARE YOU SURE
YOU WANT TO DO THAT?
BECAUSE AT -- IF --
THEY'RE BECOME--
IF THERE COMES A TIME
WHEN THERE'S AN ISSUE
AND THERE'S A CHALLENGE,
IT'S JUST AS MUCH
YOUR RESPONSIBILITY AS HERS.
YOU'RE -- YOU SHOULD BE EXPECTED
TO DO JUST AS MUCH WORK.
ASHLEY, JOSH, IT IS AN AMAZING
PHENOMENA IN SEASON SEVEN
WHAT'S HAPPENED
ON "SHARK TANK."
FOUR PEOPLE DROP OUT.
ONLY ONE PERSON PUTS UP
THE MONEY
THAT BELIEVES IN YOU...
BUT IF YOU HAVE A FIGHT
AT 50/50 --
...AND THEN YOU GET
A LOT OF NOISE AND CHATTER.
LISTEN, WORST SCENARIO --
YOU GO 49%,
BUT IF YOU HAVE
A FIGHT WITH HIM AT 50/50...
YEAH.
...IT CAN POTENTIALLY
BOTTLENECK THE COMPANY FOREVER.
IT'LL DESTROY THE COMPANY.
YEAH.
Greiner:
WELL, LISTEN, YOU GUYS --
O'Leary: LISTEN, IF THAT --
WHAT -- THIS IS ALL NOISE.
YOU GUYS HAVE AN OFFER.
THE ONLY GUY WRITING A CHECK
IS ROBERT RIGHT NOW.
I'M OUT, 'CAUSE I THINK
IT TASTES LIKE CRAP.
WOULD YOU DO 45%?
I WOULD DO 49%.
DAYMOND MADE A GOOD POINT.
I DON'T WANT
TO RUN YOUR BUSINESS.
I'VE DONE WELL IN THIS SPACE.
FOUR OR FIVE YEARS FROM NOW,
WE CAN EXTEND THIS
WITH OTHER PRODUCTS.
YOU GUYS NEED TO WORK IT,
I CAN HELP YOU.
49% I'LL GO DOWN TO.
I'LL GO 42%...
OOH.
...IF YOU DO IT RIGHT NOW.
SAY YES. DON'T HESITATE.
DO IT RIGHT NOW.
I'LL DO 42%.
DONE.
THAT'S A SHARKY MOOD
RIGHT THERE.
LOOK AT THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MAN.
PULLING ONE OUT --
RIGHT OUT OF MY PLAYBOOK.
LOOK AT THAT.
OH, THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
YOU GOT IT.
[ GIGGLES ]
IT WAS SO EXCITING
TO HAVE DAYMOND SWOOP IN.
McClelland: YEAH.
KIND OF SAVED THE DAY THERE.
IT WAS MORE OF A RELIEF.
YEAH. WHOO!
[ LAUGHS ]
IT WAS AWESOME.
IT WAS GREAT.
CONGRATULATIONS. YOU PULLED ONE
RIGHT OUT OF MY PLAYBOOK.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN LIKE THEM.
I DID LIKE IT,
IT WAS JUST TOO COSTLY.
BUT I'LL BRING THE PRICE DOWN.
I DID PRO-NRG.
I'M IN THE SPACE, AS WELL,
AND --
DAYMOND, I WANT YOU TO MAKE SURE
YOU KNOW ONE THING --
YOU JUST INVESTED IN
PANCAKE POO-POO ON A STICK.
Narrator: IN SEASON FOUR,
COUSINS JIM TSELIKIS
AND SABIN LOMAC MADE A DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN
FOR THEIR FOOD-TRUCK BUSINESS,
COUSINS MAINE LOBSTER.
BARBARA,
WELCOME TO THE FAMILY.
LET'S SEE
HOW THEY'RE DOING NOW.
Tselikis: WE ARE BACK HOME
IN PORTLAND, MAINE,
WHERE COUSINS MAINE LOBSTER
ALL STARTED.
Both: WELCOME TO MAINE!
[ CHEERING ]
Lomac: TODAY WE'VE INVITED
11 OF OUR FRANCHISEES
FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY TO COME
FIND OUT WHAT MAINE'S ALL ABOUT,
AND WHERE WE GET
OUR LOBSTER FROM.
AND WE'VE EVEN BROUGHT IN
A SPECIAL SURPRISE.
BARBARA!
[ ALL CHEERING ]
Corcoran: I'M SO EXCITED
TO BE IN MAINE TODAY.
I GET TO MEET
ALL OF MY NEW COUSINS.
I WOULDN'T MISS THIS
FOR THE WORLD.
WE'RE HEADED OUT TO SEA WITH
SOME OF OUR LOBSTERMEN,
AND WE ARE GONNA FINISH THE DAY
AT JIM'S PARENTS' HOUSE
DOING WHAT WE DO --
EATING LOBSTER.
WHEN WE GOT INTO THE BUSINESS,
WE COULD NEVER HAVE IMAGINED
FRANCHISING OUR FOOD TRUCKS,
BUT IT WAS BARB'S IDEA,
AND IT WAS
HER BEST IDEA YET.
WOW!
LOOK AT THAT THING!
Tselikis:
EACH OF OUR FRANCHISEES INVEST
BETWEEN $200,000 AND $350,000
TO START A FRANCHISE
IN THEIR CITY.
IN EXCHANGE, THEY GET
A COUSINS MAINE LOBSTER TRUCK,
OUR BRANDING, AND OUR
DAILY OPERATIONAL SUPPORT.
AS THE FRANCHISE OWNER, WE
COLLECT AN ONGOING 8% ROYALTY,
AND THEY HAVE TO BUY
OUR DELICIOUS MAINE LOBSTER
DIRECTLY FROM US.
AS THE BRAND CONTINUES TO GROW,
EVERYONE BENEFITS.
TO MY NEW COUSINS,
WELCOME TO THE FAMILY.
All: CHEERS!
COMING OUT TO MAINE HAS BEEN
A TRULY INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS,
FROM HARVESTING THE LOBSTER
TO DELIVERING IT
TO MY CUSTOMERS ON THE TRUCK.
WE STARTED WITH ONE TRUCK
IN HOUSTON.
IT'S BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL, AND NOW
WE'RE ON OUR THIRD TRUCK.
IT'S AMAZING.
WE STARTED
WITH ONE FOOD TRUCK.
WE NOW HAVE 18
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
OUR TOTAL SALES
ARE $15 MILLION.
IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS,
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE
WITH THE HELP OF "SHARK TANK"
AND BARB HAS BEEN UNBELIEVABLE.
WHAT THE NEXT THREE YEARS
HAS IN STORE, WHO KNOWS?
BUT WE'RE READY FOR IT.
All: WELCOME TO MAINE!
MY NAME'S RANDY STENGER.
I'M FROM HASTINGS, MINNESOTA.
I LIVE WITH MY FIANCéE
AND FIVE BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN,
AND I'M THE FOUNDER
OF EXTREME SANDBOX.
[ LAUGHS ]
IT WAS MY KIDS
THAT INSPIRED MY BUSINESS.
WE WERE DRIVING BY
A CONSTRUCTION SITE ONE DAY,
AND THEY WERE LIKE,
"DAD, WOULDN'T IT BE FUN
TO GO PLAY ON THAT STUFF?"
I'M LIKE,
"HECK, YEAH, IT WOULD BE."
AND THAT'S WHERE
MY BUSINESS STARTED.
WELCOME TO
EXTREME SANDBOX.
THANK YOU.
I'M RANDY.
EXTREME SANDBOX IS
A HEAVY-EQUIPMENT
ADVENTURE COMPANY
THAT LETS CLIENTS PLAY
ON CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT.
DRIVE DOWN
BETWEEN THE WHITE BARRICADES.
SO, WE HAVE LITERALLY
A 10-ACRE SANDBOX.
WE HAVE EXCAVATORS, BULLDOZERS.
WE CRUSH CARS OUT THERE.
WE MAKE CHILDHOOD DREAMS
COME TRUE EVERY DAY.
CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU JUST COMPLETED OUR COURSE.
THE EXCAVATOR, YES.
THAT IS DEFINITELY
A GOOD CHOICE.
I LEFT A STABLE JOB
MAKING SIX FIGURES
TO START THIS COMPANY.
I USED ALMOST ALL OF MY SAVINGS
AND MY RETIREMENT ACCOUNT
JUST TO GET US OFF THE GROUND.
NOW WE'RE AT THE POINT
WHERE WE WANT TO MAKE IT
A NATIONAL BRAND.
SO THAT'S REALLY WHERE
I NEED THE SHARKS,
TO TRY AND GROW THIS
SO EVERYONE CAN EXPERIENCE IT.
THIS BUSINESS MEANS
A GREAT FUTURE FOR MY FAMILY,
AND THEY'RE ALL COUNTING ON ME
TO COME HOME WITH A DEAL.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S RANDY STENGER.
I'M FROM HASTINGS, MINNESOTA,
AND I AM THE FOUNDER AND C.E.O.
OF EXTREME SANDBOX.
I'M HERE TODAY SEEKING $150,000
FOR 15% OF MY COMPANY.
SHARKS, I WANT YOU TO THINK BACK
TO YOUR CHILDHOOD DAYS.
INNOCENT, CAREFREE,
FUN-FILLED DAYS
THAT WE ALL HAVE FOND MEMORIES
OF PLAYING IN OUR SANDBOXES.
WELL, I HAVE VOWED TO REMAIN
A KID AT HEART
AND DISCOVERED
THAT THE SECRET TO YOUTH
IS TO KEEP PLAYING
IN MY SANDBOX.
HERE IS MY...
EXTREME SANDBOX.
TAKE A LOOK.
[ HEAVY METAL MUSIC PLAYS ]
EXTREME SANDBOX IS
A HEAVY-EQUIPMENT
ADVENTURE COMPANY
THAT LETS CLIENTS PLAY
ON CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT.
COOL.
OOH, I LIKE THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YES, YOU CAN COME OUT
TO DRIVE AN EXCAVATOR
OR BULLDOZER FOR FUN.
WITH OUR SUPERSIZED
10-ACRE SANDBOX,
WE PROVIDE OUR CLIENTS
A TRULY UNIQUE,
ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME,
BUCKET-LIST EXPERIENCE.
SHARKS, WE HAVE A BRAND
THAT IS REDEFINING
THE WAY ENTERTAINMENT
IS EXPERIENCED.
SO WHO'S READY TO DIG UP
SOME GOLD WITH EXTREME SANDBOX?
ALL RIGHT.
Greiner: I THINK IT'S COOL.
COOL IDEA.
I SEE
YOU'RE CRUSHING CARS.
YEP.
CAN I CRUSH A CAR?
ABSOLUTELY.
WE DO CAR CRUSHING.
WE CALL IT THE DESTRUCTION ZONE.
SO YOU CAN COME OUT
AND DEMOLISH A COUPLE --
THAT'S A -- DESTRUCTION ZONE,
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
OH, IT'S SO MUCH FUN.
HOW MUCH IS IT, RANDY?
I LIKE THAT.
I WOULD SAY OUR AVERAGE CONSUMER
PAYS ABOUT $300.
YOU KNOW, IT'S
A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME
KIND OF EXPERIENCE.
DO I GET TO CRUSH A CAR
FOR $300?
$400 GETS YOU A CAR CRUSH.
SO, WHAT'S YOUR --
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES?
WE'VE DONE $1 MILLION
IN SALES IN THREE YEARS.
OH, THREE YEARS.
SO, IT'S EXPLODING.
AND WE REALLY STARTED --
OUR FIRST YEAR WAS $140,000,
JUST PART TIME,
TO TEST OUT THE CONCEPT.
THE SECOND YEAR
WAS OUR FIRST FULL-TIME YEAR.
WE DID $280,000.
AND THEN LAST YEAR,
WE DID $400,000.
AND THEN THIS YEAR,
WE'RE ON TRACK.
WE SHOULD BE AROUND $500,000,
A LITTLE OVER HALF A MILLION.
SO, RANDY, DO YOU --
AND OUR GOAL IS
TO MAKE EVERY LOCATION
A MILLION-DOLLAR LOCATION.
DO YOU OWN THE LAND?
LIKE, I'M SURPRISED
HOW CHEAP IT IS.
THEY'RE IN MINNESOTA.
THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE, RIGHT?
WE'RE IN A SUBURB
OF MINNEAPOLIS-ST. PAUL,
ABOUT 25 MINUTES
FROM DOWNTOWN ST. PAUL.
BUT HASTINGS IS --
IT'S WITHIN THE --
WHERE'D YOU GET THE LAND?
THAT WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES TO GET STARTED,
IS TO FIND A SITE.
YOU KNOW, A CITY
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO DO IT.
WE ORIGINALLY --
I STARTED VERY LOW COST,
SO I LEASED 10 ACRES OF LAND,
I LEASED A CONSTRUCTION TRAILER,
I LEASED THREE PIECES
JUST TO TEST IT OUT.
ONCE IT TOOK OFF, I BASICALLY
BOUGHT THE LAND THAT WE WERE ON.
IT WASN'T THAT EXPENSIVE.
WHAT WAS YOUR START-UP COST,
BUYING THE BULLDOZERS,
BUYING THE BACKHOES,
BUYING...
I DON'T BUY --
DIDN'T BUY A THING.
WE LEASE EVERYTHING.
SO, PEOPLE THINK I SPENT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON THIS CONCEPT.
THE REALITY IS, I WAS JUST
REALLY SMART TO TEST IT OUT.
I-I HAVE A FIVE-YEAR LEASE
ON THEM.
I CAN TURN THEM RIGHT BACK IN,
AND I'M REALLY NOT OUT ANYTHING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
IT'S GONNA COST YOU
TO OPEN UP YOUR NEXT ONE?
ROUGHLY, I'D SAY ABOUT
$100,000 TO $120,000.
RANDY,
WHERE'S THE NEXT LOCATION?
DALLAS ACTUALLY IS A MARKET
WE'RE LOOKING AT. THERE'S A --
I'VE GOT -- I'VE GOT
PLENTY OF LAND IN DALLAS.
WHAT'S THE WORST ACCIDENT
ANYBODY'S EVER HAD?
PLEASE DON'T TALK LIKE THAT.
NO. [ CHUCKLES ]
NEVER.
WE'VE NEVER HAD AN ACCIDENT.
WE DO HAVE REMOTE ENGINE CUTOFFS
IN OUR GARAGE.
WE'VE NEVER EVEN
HAD TO USE THEM.
SO, YOU -- WHY DO YOU NEED
THE MONEY?
DO YOU WANT
TO GROW FASTER, THEN?
EXACTLY. I WANT --
I NEED IT TO GO FASTER.
I'VE USED EVERYTHING WE'VE MADE
SO FAR TO REINVEST IT.
I ENDED UP BUYING THE LAND,
BUILT A FACILITY.
BUT I DON'T HAVE THE CASH.
RANDY, WHAT IS YOUR --
YOUR, UH, HISTORY?
ARE YOU A -- WERE YOU
TRADITIONALLY IN THIS BUSINESS?
UH, I-I DON'T HAVE ANY
BACKGROUND IN CONSTRUCTION.
I WAS A POLICE OFFICER
FOR FIVE YEARS OUT IN COLORADO,
AND THEN I WANTED TO GET OUT
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I WANTED TO GET SOMETHING MORE
STABLE ONCE I STARTED A FAMILY.
WE MOVED BACK TO THE MIDWEST
'CAUSE I WAS BORN AND RAISED
IN WISCONSIN.
Greiner: HOW DO YOU SEE
YOURSELF SCALING THIS?
WHAT'S YOUR VISION
FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS?
I SEE HAVING ONE OF THESE IN
EVERY METRO AREA IN THE U.S.
I MEAN, MAYBE --
I SHOULD SAY MAYBE 10 OR SO.
WHAT I SEE IS US
ACTUALLY CENTRALIZING
ALL THE FRONT-END PROCESS.
I WOULD SAY ABOUT 30% OF OUR
WORKLOAD IS PURELY, YOU KNOW,
ANSWERING CLIENT CALLS
AND MAKING RESERVATIONS,
SELLING GIFT CERTIFICATES,
YOU KNOW,
SOCIAL-MEDIA MANAGEMENT.
ALL OF THAT CAN BE DONE
FROM THE TWIN CITIES
FOR MULTIPLE LOCATIONS.
IF YOU GOT THE RESERVATION RATE
UP OR YOU GOT MORE BOOKINGS,
HOW MUCH REVENUE
COULD THIS MODEL PRODUCE?
EACH LOCATION, I WOULD SAY,
COULD DO $1 MILLION
FAIRLY EASILY.
SO, YOU KNOW,
I COULD SEE HOW THIS COULD BE
REALLY, REALLY FUN.
YEP.
AND I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
INSIDE SEVERAL OF THESE.
AN EXCAVATOR WOULD SELL GREAT
ON QVC!
LISTEN, LISTEN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I THINK, UM, PEOPLE WOULD,
YOU KNOW,
JUST LOVE TO HAVE
THE EXPERIENCE.
IT'S --
THE --
IT'S A LOT OF FUN,
I'M SURE.
BUT I'M NOT SURE
HOW YOU'LL SCALE THIS.
SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
OKAY, SO, UM...
YEAH, I FIND IT FASCINATING.
ONLY 'CAUSE I THINK,
UH, LAST YEAR,
I WAS WALKING
ON A BEACH IN MIAMI,
THEY WERE DOING CONSTRUCTION,
AND THEY WERE MOVING THE SAND.
AND I FOUND THAT I STOOD THERE
LOOKING AT THAT CONSTRUCTION
FOR ABOUT THREE HOURS.
AND I, UH --
WELCOME TO MY WORLD.
THAT'S THE --
I WAS FASCINATED BY IT.
IT TOOK ME BACK TO A TIME
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE KID
AND I WAS EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.
UM...
WE FULFILL DREAMS OUT THERE.
IT'S THE BEST THING.
I LOVE WHAT WE DO.
YEAH.
AND SO I GET THE APPEAL.
I JUST DON'T THINK
I COULD ADD ANY VALUE.
I'M OUT.
COME ON.
SOMEONE WANTS TO PLAY.
I-I DON'T HAVE ONE OF THESE
IN MY PORTFOLIO.
[ LAUGHS ]
WE CAN DIG UP ALL THAT MONEY
YOU WANT TO GET.
I JUST
DON'T HAVE ONE OF THESE.
SORT OF A...
WE CAN MAKE THIS --
THIS WILL BE HUGE.
...VARIENTIAL...
IF YOU LOOK AT ANY --
MR. WONDERFUL'S [LAUGHS]
I MEAN, EVEN SIX FLAGS
OR DISNEY WORLD
ALWAYS STARTED
AS A SMALL ATTRACTION.
YEAH.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE THIS
HEAVY-EQUIPMENT SPACE,
WE'RE GONNA OWN.
ALL RIGHT, LOOK, YOU KNOW,
RANDY, YOU'RE A GOOD GUY,
I GET IT.
I DEFINITELY WANT
TO CRUSH A CAR.
LIKE, I'M DOING THAT
WHATEVER HAPPENS.
UM...I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $150,000 FOR 20%.
BASICALLY CLOSE
TO WHAT YOU ASKED FOR,
AND THEN YOU DECIDE
WHERE TO OPEN THE NEXT ONE.
I WISH YOU'D DO IT
NEAR BOSTON,
'CAUSE I WOULD WANT
TO CRUSH SOME CARS NEAR THERE.
ABSOLUTELY BE OPEN TO THAT.
SOME OF
MY COMPETITORS' CARS.
I LIKE THE IDEA OF JUST PICKING
THEM UP AND CRUSHING THEM.
[ CHUCKLES ]
Herjavec: RANDY, FROM
A BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE,
I THINK YOUR CHALLENGE
IS GONNA BE SCALE.
I-I DIDN'T LIKE THE FACT
YOU'RE GONNA OPEN UP ONE.
I-I THINK I WOULD'VE LIKED
TO HEAR YOU SAY,
"FOR $150,000, WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP FOUR AND ADVERTISE,"
OR SOMETHING
ALONG THAT WAY.
AND I'M NOT PASSIONATE
ABOUT
HEAVY, UH,
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT.
UM...
AND IT SEEMS KEVIN IS.
HE LIKES TO BURY HIS MONEY.
I'M OUT.
I UNDERSTAND, ROBERT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, I HAPPEN
TO LIKE THIS IDEA,
AND I LIKE THE FACT
THAT I HAVE LAND.
THIS IS THE SEVENTH SEASON
OF "SHARK TANK,"
AND I'M GONNA DO SOMETHING I
NEVER, EVER THOUGHT I WOULD DO.
IF YOU CAN CONVINCE MR. WONDER--
OH, I EVEN SAID THAT WORD.
OKAY.
[ LAUGHS ]
IF YOU CAN CONVINCE KEVIN,
UM, TO LET ME COME IN HALF
ON HIS DEAL, THEN I'LL DO IT.
AND THEN --
YOU GUYS ARE BOTH
GOING CRAZY WITH IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, I'LL DO --
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU?
I'LL DO THAT DEAL,
'CAUSE I THINK...
IS IT STILL 20%?
YEAH.
...THE LAND MATTERS,
AND OBVIOUSLY MARK KNOWS
A LOT OF GUYS IN DALLAS.
THAT'S HELPFUL.
I KNOW -- I KNOW
A LOT OF GUYS IN BOSTON.
I'D LIKE
TO SET ONE UP THERE, TOO.
I'LL DO THAT DEAL.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
DO YOU SEE AS WE --
AS LIKE ROBERT SAID --
YOU'RE STILL TALKING?
I JUST WANT TO KNOW,
WITH ACCELERATING GROWTH...
YEAH?
...IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO HELP ME WITH?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
OF COURSE.
YOU GUYS HAVE A DEAL.
WOW.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: CONGRATS.
FIRST FOR EVERYTHING.
SO EXCITING.
[ CHUCKLES ]
IT WAS FUN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
I'M COMING OUT THERE
TO CRUSH A CAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHY DID YOU LET KEVIN IN
ON THAT DEAL?
THANK YOU, GUYS.
I DON'T KNOW. IT'S STILL...
THANK YOU.
...KIND OF GOT THE HIVES FROM
DOING A DEAL WITH KEVIN,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
YOU GOT TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT.
DID THAT JUST HAPPEN?
YES! THAT'S SO AWESOME!
THIS IS SO COOL.
I CAN'T BELIEVE I GOT BOTH MARK
AND MR. WONDERFUL IN THAT DEAL.
UH, THIS IS GONNA BE
A GAME CHANGER FOR US.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A FEDERAL AGENT
WITH A WAY TO ALWAYS LOOK SHARP
AND IN CONTROL.
♪♪
HELLO, EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS DWIGHT LITTLEJOHN.
AND I'M A SPECIAL AGENT
WITH A FEDERAL AGENCY
BASED IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
I'M SEEKING $50,000 IN RETURN
FOR 25% OF MY PRODUCT,
THE TOTAL TIE KEEP.
NOW, MY CAREER
AS A FEDERAL AGENT
REQUIRES ME TO WEAR A SUIT AND
A NECKTIE JUST ABOUT EVERY DAY,
AND THAT'S BECAUSE
I'M USUALLY IN THE COMPANY
OF SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
AND IT CAN BE QUITE A CHALLENGE
TRYING TO MAINTAIN
A NEAT, PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE.
NOW, IT CAN BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO MAKE A GOOD IMPRESSION
WHEN YOU SUFFER
FROM BAD NECKTIE BEHAVIORS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SUCH AS...
THE BLOWING BENNY.
THAT'S WHEN THE WIND TAKES YOUR
TIE, WHIPS IT ACROSS YOUR FACE,
AND YOU'RE FIGHTING IT,
TRYING TO KEEP IT DOWN.
NEXT EXAMPLE IS THE PEEPING TOM.
THAT'S WHEN THAT REAR APRON
WANTS TO PEEP OUT
AND JUST BE A PART
OF WHATEVER'S GOING ON.
NEXT IS THE MESSY MARVIN.
O'Leary: NASTY.
THAT'S CHICKEN PARMESAN.
THAT'S A TRUE STORY.
[ LAUGHS ]
THE TOTAL TIE KEEP IS
THE ULTIMATE NECKTIE ACCESSORY
THAT CORRECTS, STRAIGHTENS,
AND CONTROLS THE TIE.
TIE BARS ARE VERY FANCY,
BUT SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE
THEY MAY OVER-STIFFEN THE TIE
AND TAKE AWAY THAT NATURAL FLOW.
SO, SHARKS, JOIN ME IN
STRAIGHTENING AMERICA'S TIES
WITH THE ULTIMATE
NECKTIE ACCESSORY,
THE TOTAL TIE KEEP.
I'M GONNA PASS OUT
SOME SAMPLES TO YOU.
OUTSTANDING.
Cuban:
WHICH FEDERAL AGENCY?
UM...I'M NOT AT LIBERTY
TO SAY.
[ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: IS IT
SECRET SERVICE? IS IT FBI?
I'LL TELL YOU
EVERYTHING YOU WANT TO KNOW
WHEN WE'RE SIGNING A DEAL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
UH, THE PACKAGE
IS MY BASIC COLLECTION.
IT'S FOUR DIFFERENT COLORS,
AND THOSE COLORS
CAN BE WORN TO...
OH, I SEE.
...COORDINATE WITH
THE TIE OR THE SHIRT.
THAT'S COOL.
FIRST, YOU JUST WANT TO PUT YOUR
TIE ON LIKE YOU NORMALLY DO,
TURN IT OVER,
AND YOU FIND THE TIE LOOP.
YOU WANT TO COUNT UP TWO BUTTONS
FROM THIS TIE LOOP -- ONE, TWO.
AND THAT'S WHERE YOU WANT
TO ATTACH THE TIE KEEP TO.
NOW, YOU WANT TO TAKE
THIS REAR APRON
AND TUCK IT IN THIS UPPER LOOP,
RIGHT -- KABAM.
SO, THE NEXT STEP
YOU WANT TO DO,
YOU TAKE THE WHOLE ENTIRE DEVICE
AND TUCK IT BEHIND THE TIE LOOP.
AND THEN YOU WANT
TO SECURE THAT.
AND THEN YOU CAN SECURE
THE MIDDLE BUTTON, ALSO,
JUST TO GIVE IT
AN EXTRA BIT OF SECURITY.
THAT'S SLICK.
AW. THAT'S COOL.
WHY DIDN'T
YOU THINK OF THAT?
AND THERE YOU GO.
O'Leary: THAT'S VERY COOL.
Herjavec:
SO, DWIGHT, I GOT TO KNOW.
UH-HUH?
THERE YOU ARE
GUARDING SOMEBODY, HIGH SECRET,
REALLY SENSITIVE,
AND YOU'RE THINKING,
"MAN, I GOT TO COME UP WITH
A TIE-CLIP IDEA."
WELL, JUST --
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
THE IDEA?
WELL, GOING THROUGH JUST
DAY-TO-DAY WORK, SEEING PEOPLE,
MEETING OTHER AGENTS
FROM DIFFERENT AGENCIES,
I MEAN, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
IS WHAT WE CALL
COMMAND PRESENCE.
THAT'S THAT SENSE
OF WALKING INTO A ROOM
AND JUST KIND OF CONTROLLING
THE ROOM WITHOUT SAYING A WORD.
AND OBVIOUSLY
YOU HAVE TO LOOK THE PART
IN ABLE FOR THAT
TO BE EFFECTIVE.
DWIGHT, WOULD YOU GIVE ONE
TO KEVIN?
'CAUSE HE'S DOING
THE PEEPING TOM RIGHT NOW.
YEAH, THAT'S --
THAT'S -- THAT'S --
I CAN SEE IT RIGHT HERE.
THAT'S FOR KEVIN.
I LOOK SPECTACULAR
ALL THE TIME.
THAT -- THAT'S FOR YOU.
THOSE ARE FOR YOU.
HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
THEY RETAIL FOR $25
FOR A PACK OF FOUR,
UM, AND IT ONLY COSTS ME
A LITTLE UNDER $3.
HAVE YOU SOLD ANY?
ARE YOU ALREADY SELLING THEM?
NOT REALLY.
THIS IS THE TRICKY PART,
AND THIS IS WHY I'M HERE.
YOU GOT A JOB, AND --
[ LAUGHS ]
EXACTLY. IT'S -- IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO FIND TIME
TO GET INTO IT
LIKE I WANT TO.
OKAY, SO, YOU'RE COMING IN
WITH A CONCEPT...
WELL...
...SO TO SPEAK.
AND IT'S PATENTED,
OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S PATENTED.
UM, I HAVE SOLD SOME
ON-- ONLINE.
I GIVE A LOT OF THEM AWAY
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT ASSIST ME ON THE ROAD.
AND I HAVE SOLD SOME TO --
DO THEY WEAR THEM?
THEY DO.
THEY ABSOLUTELY DO.
AND I HAVE, UM, PRETTY MUCH
EXHAUSTED MY SALES CIRCLE,
SO TO SPEAK.
John: HAVE YOU TRIED TO PUT THIS
IN ANY RETAIL?
I DID. I ACTUALLY WENT INTO A --
I WALKED INTO A MEN'S WEARHOUSE.
UH-HUH.
UM, THEY HOOKED ME UP WITH
THEIR TIE-ACCESSORY GUY,
AND I ENDED UP GETTING
200 UNITS SOLD,
AND THEN THEY PUT IT
ON THEIR WEBSITE FOR TESTING.
HOW DID THEY SELL?
BUT THEY DIDN'T --
THEY DIDN'T DO A VERY GOOD JOB.
THE PUT IT ON A BACK PAGE.
UM, AND OBVIOUSLY THIS NEEDS
TO BE EXPLAINED,
AS FAR AS
ALL OF THE ADVANTAGES IT HAS.
I THINK -- I THINK
YOUR BIGGER PROBLEM IS
YOU WENT TO THE BIGGEST COMPANY
IN THE SPACE...
INSTEAD OF LITTLE.
...INSTEAD OF ANY OF THESE
SPECIALTY STORES,
BECAUSE THE MORE THEY SELL,
THE MORE YOU MAKE,
THE MORE THEY MAKE,
THEY RE-ORDER QUICKLY.
YOU KNOW, SOMEWHERE LIKE
A BIG MEN'S WEARHOUSE,
THAT'S A HUGE SYSTEM.
YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M SAYING?
AND --
AND I THINK THAT, UM,
YOU PROBABLY WENT TO
THE WRONG COMPANY.
THIS IS -- THIS IS WHY
I NEED YOU GUYS.
YOU NEED US
'CAUSE YOU GOT NO SALES.
Herjavec: DWIGHT,
HOW WOULD THIS WORK?
YOU HAVE A FULL-TIME JOB.
MM-HMM.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA QUIT
YOUR FULL-TIME JOB.
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR $50,000.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH THE MONEY?
LIKE -- LIKE -- WHERE'S --
WHO'S GONNA GO OUT AND SELL IT?
EVEN IF YOU GOT
THE $50,000,
TELL ME
WHAT HAPPENS TOMORROW.
WELL, IF -- IF I GOT
THE $50,000,
I WOULD USE THAT
TO BUY MORE PRODUCT.
'CAUSE OBVIOUSLY, WITH YOUR
INVESTMENT, I WOULD EXPECT --
NO, I GOT IT.
BUT WHO'S GONNA SELL IT?
WELL, I WOULD EXPECT --
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
THAT'S WHY I CAME IN ASKING FOR
A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY
FOR A HIGHER PERCENTAGE
OF THE COMPANY,
HOPING TO GET ASSISTANCE
FROM YOU ALL.
BUT, DWIGHT,
SOMEONE'S GOT TO WORK THERE.
I MEAN, THERE'S ALWAYS --
SOMEONE'S GOT TO BE AT THAT
BUSINESS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
YEAH, I --
WHO'S IT GONNA BE?
WELL, I-IT COULD BE ME
TO A CERTAIN EXTENT.
UM, BUT THAT'S WHEN I NEED
SOME OF YOU GUYS
TO KIND OF STEP IN --
BUT YOU CAN'T GIVE UP YOUR
FULL-TIME GIG.
I MEAN,
THIS IS A GREAT IDEA,
AND A PRODUCT THAT'S MISSING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT'S KIND OF WHY I WANT TO GET
INTO LICENSING, ALSO.
I MEAN, THAT'S ALWAYS
A POSSIBILITY.
LOOK --
YOU KNOW, I JUST --
I JUST NEED --
THERE'S -- THERE'S NO
INFRASTRUCTURE...
I JUST NEED HELP.
Greiner: YOU DON'T WANT
TO BE DOING THIS.
I NEED HELP.
YOU REALLY WANT SOMEBODY
WHO'S GOING TO TAKE IT OVER.
WHETHER LICENSING, WHETHER THEY
BUY YOU OUT, WHATEVER IT IS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO RUN THIS
DAY TO DAY.
I-I CAN'T AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT IN MY LIFE.
THE REASON I DON'T WEAR A TIE
IS MY FIRST COMPANY,
MicroSolutions, I BOUGHT
MY FIRST SUITS TWO FOR $99.
ALL THE TIES
THAT I BOUGHT WERE USED.
I COULDN'T AFFORD
TO BUY A NEW TIE.
I HAD TO WEAR A TIE EVERY
SINGLE DAY THAT I WENT TO WORK.
THE MINUTE I SOLD
THAT COMPANY, I SAID,
"I'M NOT WEARING ANOTHER DARN
TIE FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE."
[ CHUCKLES ]
TO ME, SWAG ISN'T ABOUT
WHAT I WEAR.
SWAG IS ME BEING ABLE
TO TELL EVERYBODY AROUND ME
WHAT TO WEAR.
I'M NOT THE RIGHT GUY.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
TO MARK'S POINT,
I'M NOT THE RIGHT PARTNER HERE.
I CANNOT RELATE AT ALL
TO TIES.
I HAVE ZERO EXPERIENCE
THERE.
I'M NOT THE RIGHT PARTNER
FOR YOU.
I WISH YOU LUCK,
BUT I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I MEAN,
I'VE TAKEN IT THIS FAR.
I MEAN, THAT HAS TO COUNT
FOR SOMETHING, RIGHT?
I MEAN, LOOK, YOU'VE INVENTED
A PRODUCT WITH NO SALES,
SO THE QUESTION IS...
I HAVE SALES.
THEY'RE JUST NOT OFFICIAL.
...YOU'RE ASKING A VALUATION OF
$200,000 FOR IT RIGHT NOW.
I THINK I'D HAVE TO GET 116%
OF THE COMPANY
FOR THE $50,000
YOU'RE ASKING FOR.
WELL, THAT -- THAT VALUATION
IS BASED ON SOMETHING.
IT'S NOT ANYTHING
I JUST THREW OUT THERE.
WHAT IS IT BASED ON?
WHAT -- WHAT IS IT?
WELL, I HAVE, UH, ABOUT
5,200 BOXES,
AND THEY CAN RETAIL
FROM ANYWHERE BETWEEN
$50,000 AND $100,000.
YEAH,
BUT THEY'RE NOT RETAILING.
DWIGHT --
BUT I HAVEN'T --
ONCE I START MAKING AN EFFORT
TO GET IT THERE,
I-I'M PRETTY SURE THAT THEY CAN.
DWIGHT, YOU'RE GONNA SELL OUT
OF THE INVENTORY YOU HAVE
WHEN PEOPLE SEE IT PARTLY 'CAUSE
IT'S A GOOD PRODUCT,
PARTLY BECAUSE
YOU'RE A GREAT GUY
AND YOU COME ACROSS
REALLY WELL.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
STARTING A BUSINESS
ISN'T A PART-TIME JOB.
A-AND --
YOU CAN'T BE A WANT-TREPRENEUR.
YEAH, I'M --
I HAVE A FULL-TIME JOB.
I CAN'T DO IT FOR YOU.
AND I THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW,
I WI-- I WISH YOU THE BEST,
BUT YOU KIND OF
CAN'T DO BOTH.
YEAH.
I'M OUT.
GOTCHA.
O'Leary: MY PROBLEM IS,
I'M IN IT FOR THE MONEY.
I GIVE YOU $50,000,
NEXT MONTH I CALL YOU SAYING,
"HOW MUCH MONEY
HAVE I MADE?"
AND YOU SAY,
"WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?"
[ CUBAN LAUGHS ]
YOU TELL ME, "IF YOU ASK ME
THIS AGAIN, I'LL ARREST YOU."
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DON'T LIKE THAT OUTCOME.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
IT'S NOT A BUSINESS,
IT'S A HOBBY,
AND IT HAS NO SALES.
I'M OUT.
DWIGHT, I CAN'T HAVE MY MONEY
BECOME TUITION
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T FIGURED
ANYTHING OUT JUST YET.
AT THIS STAGE,
I HAVE TO BE OUT.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD LUCK, DWIGHT.
GOOD LUCK.
I APPRECIATE IT.
ALL RIGHT. TAKE CARE.
I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE SALES AREN'T GREAT,
BUT I'M LEARNING
AS I MOVE FORWARD,
AND I'M GETTING BETTER AT IT.
AND AS I GET BETTER,
MY COMPANY WILL GET BETTER,
AND MY SALES WILL GET BETTER.
DO YOU GUYS LIKE IT?
Cuban: YES.
WOULD YOU BUY IT?
NO.
I'M GONNA USE IT.
THE RARE TIMES
I HAVE TO WEAR A TIE,
I'M GONNA USE IT.
THE PROBLEM IS IT COSTS MORE
THAN CUBAN'S SUITS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
NOT MUCH MORE.
♪♪
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A FIREFIGHTER
WITH A SOLUTION
TO PREVENT KITCHEN FIRES.
HI, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS PETER THORPE.
I AM THE CREATOR AND FOUNDER
OF FireAvert.
I AM SEEKING $300,000
FOR A 7% STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
I'M A FIREFIGHTER AND...
...AN ENTREPRENEUR.
SHARKS, EVERY
FOUR AND A HALF MINUTES,
FIREFIGHTERS JUST LIKE ME
RESPOND TO A HOME FIRE
BECAUSE SOMEBODY FORGOT
ABOUT THE FOOD
COOKING ON THE STOVE.
THAT'S WHY I CREATED FireAvert.
FireAvert IS A SIMPLE DEVICE
THAT ANYONE CAN INSTALL.
YOU SIMPLY PLUG YOUR STOVE
INTO FireAvert,
FireAvert IN THE WALL,
AND IT'S READY TO GO.
WHEN THE SMOKE ALARM SOUNDS
FROM THE FOOD STARTING TO BURN,
FireAvert WILL HEAR
YOUR SMOKE ALARM,
CUT POWER TO YOUR STOVE,
ELIMINATE THE HEAT SOURCE,
AND PREVENT ANY POSSIBLE
FIRE FROM STARTING.
LET ME DEMONSTRATE THIS
FOR YOU NOW.
[ SMOKE ALARM BEEPING ]
Herjavec: OH.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
FireAvert WAS ABLE
TO HEAR THE SOUND
OF YOUR SMOKE ALARM
AND TURN OFF THE STOVE
BEFORE THERE WAS ANY FIRE.
SO, SHARKS, WHO WANTS
TO PROTECT PROPERTY
AND SAVE LIVES WITH FireAvert?
IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
LET ME GET LORI HERS.
THANK YOU.
PETER, IN YOUR EXAMPLE,
IT TURNED IT OFF,
WHICH WAS GREAT.
BUT FOR THE SMOKE ALARM
TO GO OFF,
WOULDN'T THERE ALREADY BE
A LOT OF SMOKE,
AND THE FIRE ALREADY GOING
ON THE STOVE?
SO, GREAT QUESTION.
WE -- AS -- AS A FIREFIGHTER,
FROM MY EXPERIENCE,
AND FROM NUMEROUS TESTS, WE KNOW
THAT SMOKE PRECEDES FIRE.
I'VE BEEN ON DOZENS OF CALLS
WHERE THERE IS NO FIRE,
IT'S JUST SMOKE DAMAGE.
THIS IS THE NUMBER-ONE CAUSE
OF HOME FIRES IN THE U.S.
WE ARE PREVENTION.
DOES IT WORK FOR GAS?
FOR RIGHT NOW, WE ONLY WORK
FOR ELECTRIC STOVES.
WHY ONLY STOVES?
THAT'S THE NUMBER-ONE CAUSE
OF HOME FIRES IN THE U.S.
HOW LONG
HAVE YOU BEEN SELLING THIS?
WE'VE BEEN ON THE MARKET
FOR 18 MONTHS.
AND HOW'S IT GOING?
AND HOW MUCH IS IT?
IT MSRPs FOR $195.
$195?
$195.
WOW.
I'M SURPRISED.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
A LOT LESS.
Greiner: I DID, TOO.
I THOUGHT
IT WAS GONNA BE LIKE...
29 BUCKS.
HOW MUCH
DO YOU MAKE IT FOR?
WE MAKE THIS FOR $45.
DANG.
WOW.
TELL ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE VALUE.
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S WORTH
ROUGHLY $4.5 MILLION TODAY.
YEAH.
HOW DID YOU
COME UP WITH THAT?
SO, I KNOW WE'RE GONNA HIT
AT LEAST $2 MILLION THIS YEAR.
HOW MUCH MONEY WOULD YOU MAKE
ON THE $2 MILLION?
RIGHT NOW, THIS YEAR,
WE HAVE A 37% NET PROFIT.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE $750,000.
YES.
DAMN!
PETER, YOU ARE ON FIRE.
HOW IS THE WORD GETTING OUT
THAT PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THIS?
YEAH, SO, WE SELL DIRECT
TO MULTI-FAMILY HOUSING
AND SENIOR-HOUSING FACILITIES.
IF YOU CAN IMAGINE, THESE
MULTI-FAMILY-HOUSING OWNERS
THAT ARE HAVING A STOVE FIRE
ONCE A QUARTER
IN THEIR PORTFOLIO,
IT'S A HUGE PAIN POINT FOR THEM,
AND WE CAN SHOW
THEM THE SOLUTION.
IT'S A NO-BRAINER FOR THEM.
DO YOU OWN
THE COMPANY YOURSELF?
I STARTED IT.
I OWN JUST UNDER
30% OF THE COMPANY NOW.
OHH.
YOU OWN WHAT?
WAIT, YOU OWN JUST 30%?
CORRECT.
OH.
WHO OWNS THE REST, PETER?
SO, WHEN I HAD THE IDEA --
I'M A FIREFIGHTER, RIGHT?
AND SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
AND WE TOOK SOME EARLY FRIENDS,
TOOK SOME INVESTMENTS,
THEY OWN A PART OF IT.
PETER, WHO IS THE LARGEST
SHAREHOLDER OF YOUR COMPANY?
IS IT YOU
OR ONE OF YOUR FRIENDS?
ONE OF MY FRIENDS.
HOW MUCH DOES YOUR FRIEND OWN,
A SINGLE INDIVIDUAL?
UH, ONE OF THEM OWNS 60%.
OHH.
I NEEDED CASH, AND I WAS PAYING
FOR THE BUSINESS OUT OF POCKET.
THE BUSINESS IS BURNING MONEY,
RIGHT?
AND I WAS TO THE POINT
WHERE WE WERE PRE-SALES.
I GOT FOUR KIDS,
AND I WAS PUTTING MY MORTGAGE
ON A CREDIT CARD.
I HAD PUT ALL MY SAVINGS
INTO IT.
I -- I WAS STRESSING. I --
YOU WERE STUCK.
I FEEL LIKE HE SAVED ME.
THAT'S FINE. YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T THINK HE SAVED YOU.
AT LEAST FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
IF YOU WATCH THE SHOW A LOT,
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN ME
TRY TO GET 50% OR 51%.
AND THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT --
BECAUSE I THINK
THE ENTREPRENEUR HAS TO HAVE
ENOUGH STAKE IN THE GAME.
OTHERWISE, THERE'LL BE A POINT
OF DIMINISHING RETURNS
WHERE YOU QUESTION
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S WORTH IT,
OR YOU'LL LOOK
TO DO SOMETHING ELSE
BECAUSE
YOU'RE AN ENTREPRENEUR.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S
GONNA BE AN ISSUE HERE,
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE,
YOU BECOME AN ENTREPRENEUR
TO SAVE LIVES
AS WELL AS MAKE MONEY.
BUT, UH, YOU KNOW, GIVING AWAY,
UM, 70% OF YOUR COMPANY
AT THE EARLY STAGES, NOW YOU
HAVE LIMITED TO PLAY WITH.
AND, UH, YOU KNOW,
I THINK THAT I WOULD MAKE IT
JUST MORE PRESSURE ON YOU.
SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
Greiner: WELL, LISTEN.
I AGREE WITH DAYMOND.
YOU WERE IN A CIRCUMSTANCE
WHERE YOU GAVE AWAY A LOT
FOR A LITTLE.
BUT YOU WERE STUCK,
SO YOU DID IT.
NOW YOU'RE IN
A POSITION AGAIN
WHERE YOU'RE GIVING AWAY
MORE OF YOUR COMPANY, RIGHT?
SO, I-I PERSONALLY FEEL
THAT I DON'T WANT TO TAKE
MORE OF YOUR COMPANY.
I DON'T FEEL RIGHT
ABOUT IT.
GOOD LUCK.
BUT RIGHT NOW, I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU'RE
REALLY SMALL, YOU GOT TO HANG ON
TO AS MUCH EQUITY
AS LONG AS YOU CAN.
I WANT TO GET INVOLVED,
BUT 5%, 7%,
JUST NOT THAT INTERESTED.
SO, MAKE AN OFFER.
TELL ME WHAT YOU GUYS THINK
IT WOULD BE WORTH
FOR YOU GUYS GETTING UP
AND BEING PART OF THIS COMPANY.
I BELIEVE IN THIS PRODUCT.
I FEEL THAT THIS IS GONNA BE
IN EVERY HOME ACROSS AMERICA.
WE ALL BELIEVE IN THIS,
WE JUST DON'T --
IT'S NOT A QUESTION
ABOUT THE PRODUCT.
YEAH.
THE PRODUCT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
IT'S THE DEAL.
WE ALL LIKE THE PRODUCT.
OKAY, HOW ABOUT --
SO, WHAT -- WHAT DEAL
MAKES SENSE?
PETER,
HOW ABOUT THIS DEAL?
IS THERE...
I BUY OUT YOUR FRIEND'S 60%
FOR $300,000
AND GIVE YOU
51% VOTING CONTROL.
HE'S GONE.
I'LL BE THE 60% GUY.
Narrator: THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
EVERYONE IS CONCERNED
PETER GAVE AWAY TOO MUCH
OF HIS FIRE-PREVENTION COMPANY,
FireAvert,
TO A PREVIOUS INVESTOR.
BUT KEVIN HAS
A UNIQUE PROPOSITION.
O'Leary:
HOW ABOUT THIS DEAL?
I BUY OUT YOUR FRIEND'S 60%
FOR $300,000
AND GIVE YOU
51% VOTING CONTROL.
I'LL GIVE YOU, IN MY DEAL --
I'LL TAKE OUT YOUR FRIEND.
I SIT IN HIS SHOES.
I NOW HAVE 60%.
BUT I DON'T WANT
TO CONTROL YOUR COMPANY.
John: SO, HIS FRIEND
IS GONNA SAY, "WAIT A MINUTE.
WE'RE GONNA CLEAR $750,000,"
UH, YOU KNOW --
THAT HE OWNS 60% OF,
RIGHT?
YEAH, YOUR FRIEND IS NOT GONNA
BE A FRIEND ANYMORE.
John: I OWN 60% OF THAT.
YEAH, BUT HIS FRIEND
RIGHT NOW --
IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT YOU THINK.
WITH THIS FRIEND, ALSO, HE'S
A VERY STRATEGIC PARTNER, TOO.
Cuban: WHAT'S HIS NAME?
UH, JEFF.
HE'S A MULTI-FAMILY-HOUSING
OWNER HIMSELF,
AND SO HE'S BEEN ABLE
TO -- TO OPEN DOORS FOR ME.
HE'S VERY STRATEGIC.
HE'S GOT ME
SO MUCH NETWORKING OUT THERE.
BUT YOU DO UNDERSTAND
HE OWNS 60%
SO THAT HE CAN MAKE
THE FINAL DECISION?
WHY ARE WE EVEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS
WHEN JEFF ISN'T HERE
AND HE CAN'T SELL JEFF OUT?
YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
WELL, IT'S GONNA BE
A CONTINGENCY.
I'M ASKING.
IT'LL BE A CONTINGENCY.
BECAUSE WHAT IT GETS YOU BACK
IS CONTROL OF YOUR COMPANY.
I'M -- I AM YOUR FRIEND.
THAT'S WHY I'M --
WHY WOULD JEFF SELL OUT 60%
FOR $300,000?
MAYBE HE WANTS
LIQUIDITY.
HOW MUCH DID HE SPEND?
$50,000.
WOW.
O'Leary: HE GAVE YOU $50,000.
I'M NOW OFFERING HIM $300,000
FOR HIS $50,000.
TOTAL LIQUIDITY.
WHY DON'T YOU JUST CALL HIM?
LET'S FIND OUT.
PETER, I'LL MAKE YOU
A BETTER OFFER THAN KEVIN
ON THE SAME TERMS.
I'LL GIVE YOU $400,000
FOR THAT 60%,
AND I'LL GIVE YOU BACK
THE VOTING RIGHTS, ALSO.
I DON'T NEED
TO RUN YOUR BUSINESS.
I'LL GIVE YOU
VOTING CONTROL.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET'S GO CALL JEFF.
I'M GONNA TALK TO JEFF.
LET'S DO IT.
♪♪
JEFF?
THIS IS MARK CUBAN.
I'M HERE WITH PETER.
SAY HI, PETER.
HEY, JEFF. HOW ARE YOU?
JEFF: Good. Hey, Peter.
Hey, Mark.
THE QUESTION
THAT WE ALL HAD WAS,
WITH PETER ONLY HAVING
30% LEFT,
IT MADE IT A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO INVEST
BECAUSE HE'D BE DILUTED,
AND WE WERE CONCERNED
WITH THE AMOUNT OF EQUITY
HE'D HAVE AFTER A DEAL.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO SELL
ANY OF YOUR EQUITY
DIRECTLY AS PART OF THIS DEAL
SO THAT THE MONEY WENT TO YOU
SO THAT PETER WOULD BE ABLE
TO RETAIN HIS EQUITY?
REALLY WHAT IT'S COME DOWN TO,
THERE'S KEVIN
AND, UM, ROBERT ARE LOOKING
AT MAKING OFFERS.
KEVIN'S OFFER WAS $300,000
TO BUY YOUR EQUITY DIRECTLY,
AND THE SECOND OPTION WAS
FROM ROBERT, HE'D GIVE $400,000.
I know Robert and Kevin are
obviously accomplished guys,
but I highly doubt they would be
more strategic in this business
than I am.
I'M GONNA LET YOU TALK
TO, UM, PETER,
AND LET YOU GUYS
FIGURE IT OUT
AND DECIDE IF YOU WANT
TO COUNTER OR NOT.
Sounds good.
THANK YOU.
Thanks.
I THINK IT IS CRAZY
THEY WANT TO OFFER
$300,000, $400,000
FOR ALL YOUR EQUITY.
Well, don't let
the bright lights
have us do a dumb deal.
Herjavec:
SO, WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
DOES HE WANT
TO SELL HIS POSITION?
THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE DISCUSSING.
OKAY, PETER, BEFORE YOU START,
JUST TO SUMMARIZE HERE
SO I AM CLEAR ON WHAT
THE SITUATION IS WITH JEFF --
HE GAVE YOU $50,000
AND GOT 60% OF THE COMPANY.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS.
I'LL BUY JEFF'S POSITION,
THE ENTIRE 60%, FOR $300,000.
IS HE INTERESTED
IN DOING THAT?
JEFF SAID HE WILL NOT SELL
HIS FULL EQUITY FOR $300,000.
HE WANTS TO STAY IN THE GAME.
WE WANT TO DILUTE EQUALLY.
SO, HE'S NOT OPPOSED
TO DILUTING,
BUT HE WON'T SELL
ANY OF HIS SHARES DIRECTLY.
YES.
I HAVE ZERO INTEREST IN THAT.
I'M OUT.
IF THAT'S THE CASE,
I'M OUT, TOO.
LORI, I WISH YOU WERE STILL IN,
BECAUSE I THINK --
I THINK WE CAN SELL
A LOT OF THESE ON QVC.
THERE IS A HUGE MARKET OUT THERE
FOR PEOPLE BUYING THESE
FOR THEIR PARENTS,
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR PARENTS AGING AND PLACE.
I TOLD YOU MY COST RIGHT NOW
IS $45.
I KNOW FOR A FACT WE CAN GET
THE COST OF THIS DOWN TO $20.
AND THEN WHAT
WOULD YOU SELL IT FOR?
WE COULD SALE THIS RETAIL
FOR $99 ON QVC OR OTHER PLACES.
WHAT ARE YOU OFFERING ME?
SO -- SO, LORI --
YOU CAME BACK IN HERE,
AND YOU LOOKED AT ME.
YEAH.
[ LAUGHS ]
WHAT'S YOUR OFFER TO ME?
LORI --
I'M INTERESTED.
SO, $300,000 --
WHAT ABOUT $300,000 FOR 12%?
I WOULD DO IT THIS WAY
INSTEAD.
THIS IS BASED ON THAT
YOU GET THE UNIT PRICE DOWN.
I WOULD GO $300,000 AS A LOAN,
5% INTEREST.
JUST GIVE ME 15% ROYALTY
UNTIL I'M PAID BACK.
AND THEN,
WHEN I GOT BACK MY $300,000,
I WOULD HAVE
THE 12% STAKE.
O'Leary: I CAN BEAT THAT OFFER
IN A BIG WAY.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $300,000,
ALSO AS A LOAN,
I'LL TAKE A 10% ROYALTY
UNTIL I'M PAID BACK $900,000.
MY ROYALTY GOES AWAY.
UNTIL $900,000.
AND I ONLY WANT --
I ONLY WANT 5% OF YOUR EQUITY.
LORI, $300,000, 10% ROYALTY
UNTIL YOU'RE PAID BACK,
AND THEN YOU OWN 10% EQUITY.
WE'RE GONNA DO
$2 MILLION THIS YEAR.
WE'VE ALREADY DONE $1.5 MILLION.
$300,000 LOAN.
10% ROYALTY
UNTIL I'M PAID BACK $400,000.
THEN THE ROYALTY ENDS,
AND THEN I HAVE 10% EQUITY
STAKE IN THE COMPANY.
DEAL.
OH, MY GOD!
OKAY.
WHOO-HOO!
THAT WAS A SWITCHEROO, BOY.
THAT WENT AROUND
QUITE A BIT, RIGHT?
OH, MY GOD.
CONGRATULATIONS, PETER.
THANK YOU. YEP.
WOW.
Thorpe: THIS DEAL MEANS
EVERYTHING TO MY FAMILY.
AND GIVING UP THAT MUCH
EQUITY IN THE BEGINNING
I STILL STAND BEHIND.
WITH LORI'S NETWORK
AND MARKETING ABILITIES
TO GET THIS OUT TO THE MASSES
AND BUILD AWARENESS
IS WHY I WANTED
TO WORK WITH HER.